und jetzt wird es aber richtig mysteriös
einerseits freuen wir uns in Deutschland
über einen neuen Höchststand bei den
Erwerbstätigen rund 46 Millionen Meldung
aus dieser Woche andererseits klagen
diverse Branchen über Fachkräftemangel
wie geht das zusammen ja ist wirklich
das große Rätsel Pflege
Gastronomie Handwerk alle suchen
Händeringen Personal und fragen sich wo
sind die Leute die Arbeitskräfte sind
nicht weg die sind nur woanders so Gott
sei Dank ja sagt man Anlageberater auch
immer ihr Geld ist nicht weg das gehört
jetzt nur wem anders
tatsächlich gibt es den Fachkräftemangel
natürlich aber er ist darauf weisen
jetzt immer mehr Ökonomen hin in vielen
Branchen halt auch selbst verschuldet
oder mit verschuldet die Zauberworte
lauten Bezahlung und Arbeitsbedingungen
wer hätte das gedacht ne der
Arbeitnehmer ist plötzlich ja ein
knapper Rohstoff und der Arbeitgeber
muss dann halt manchmal nehmen was noch
da ist
seine Ansprüche sogar schon
heruntergeschraubt ohne bestimmte
Sprachkenntnisse und vielleicht auch
ohne Ausbildung lediglich den Willen
mitbringen morgens um 7 Uhr hier mit uns
zusammen anfangen zu wollen
7 Uhr ja ach 7 Uhr morgens um Gottes
Willen nein ist er verrückt morgens nein
danke ja ein gutes Beispiel übrigens für
selber schuld ist in diesem Zusammenhang
ist die Pflegebranche ja laut einer
Bremer Studie würden von den Menschen
die in den letzten Jahren fluchtartig
ihren Job in der Pflege gekündigt haben
60% zurückkommen wenn sich die
Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern hinzu
besseren personalschlüsseln fallen als
Beispiel oder so kritis klingt so
bessere Bezahlung Deutschland hat sich
Jahre Aufschwung hinter sich von dem
aber die unteren Einkommensschichten
viel zu wenig profitiert haben und dann
wird gemeckert wie heute wenn ein
Flughäfen für mehr Lohn gestreikt wird
langsam entstehen aber neue
Machtverhältnisse auf dem Markt jetzt
müssen sich die Unternehmen reinhängen
und zwar mit allen Mitteln
tanzen gegen den Fachkräftemangel um
sich von der Konkurrenz abzuheben setzt
ein Familienunternehmen auf Kreativität
Videos auf tiktok sollen neue
Mitarbeiter anlocken
ja man möchte sich direkt bewerben nur
damit der aufhört zu tanzen
es war ja gut gemeint Freunde
Negativbeispiele sind Gastronomie und
Hotelerie viele haben da in der
corona-zeit reihenweise Leute für die
Tür gesetzt die Staatshilfen lieber für
sich selber genommen und jammern jetzt
dass keiner zurückkommt die
Erfolgsformel für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland unser
Geheimnis lautete über Jahre Export plus
großer Niedriglohnsektor funktioniert so
beides nicht mehr ich finde das schreit
nach neuen Ideen nein das schreit nach
neuen Sendungen
jetzt neu bei RTL 10 einsame
Jungunternehmer leiden unter
Fachkräftemangel und buhlen um den
Mitarbeiter ihrer Träume
Fachkraft Island sie alle brauchen ihn
dringend aber nur einer geht mit ihm
nach Hause Dieter 58
anlagenmechatroniker mit großen Lücken
im Lebenslauf ich sag's lieber direkt
ich habe einen Alkoholproblem und will
mindestens 7000 brutto
was ist noch mal mehr wo man merkte ein
absoluter Traumtyp doch wer bekommt ihn
verzweifelte Firmenchefs auf der Jagd
nach der letzten Fachkraft übrigens
damit das klar ist mittwochs kann ich
nicht da stand ich aus verliebt dich neu
bei Fachkraft eilen ach ja und ich habe
keinen Führerschein einer müsste mich
morgens abholen
ja
das ist die Zukunft
es ist ja so wir müssen als Gesellschaft
endlich über den wahren Wert der Arbeit
reden nicht zuletzt in kehrberufen
Beispiel Kita oder noch ein Beispiel
Friseursalons Salons die jahrelang
vergeblichen neue Azubis gesucht haben
schaffen jetzt gerade die Wände mit der
Einführung der vier Tage Woche ich will
sagen zumindest ein Teil des Problems
kann doch hier vor Ort gelöst werden was
er jetzt nicht ausschließt dass man auch
im Ausland nach Fachkräften sucht wie
unser Finanzminister
okay
haben das gesehen eine hat sich gemeldet
ja die wollte wissen ob sie aufs Klo
darf ne also der Grünkohl König hat echt
eine Pechsträhne die jungen Menschen
werden eben immer selbstbewusster gerade
die Geburten schwachen Jahrgänge wissen
ja um ihre neue Verhandlungsposition um
ihre neue macht keine einfachen Zeiten
also für Unternehmer vom alten Schlag
Ulrich von Heesen rechnet ab mit der
Jensi hör mir doch auf mit dieser
Generation Z ist nicht nur im Alphabet
das hinterletzte diese verwöhnten
Bratzen haben nie gelernt was harte
Arbeit eigentlich bedeutet
46% der Angestellten zwischen 18 und 25
fühlen sich schon nach einem Tag im Büro
müde und ausgelaugt
wenn man nicht ausgelaugt ist was gar
keine Arbeit hat uns damals auch nicht
geschadet glück ist wenn der Chef
glücklich ist ja aber meine
work-balance einfach mal ins Maul halten
mit der Einstellung hätte ich meine
Firma nie aufgebaut also ich habe sie
damals geerbt aber das ist ja gar nicht
geboren ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf
die Anspruchshaltung von diesen
laktosefreien Nussallergiker ich
beschäftige jetzt nur noch Leute die vor
1950 geboren sind mein guter Heinrich
hier der weiß gar nicht wie man vier
Tage Woche schreibt
nicht ich sehe noch lauter
löwenzahn ist ein guter Mann auf die
Generation kann sich verlassen
der kriegt er ist Burnout wenn ich sie
mal erlaube und dann heulen einem die
Kinder auch noch die Ohren voll wegen
Klima statt sich zu freuen dass ich ein
geiles Leben hatte scheiß
Neidgesellschaft ich lasse mir von
keinem junge Menschen mehr irgendetwas
sagen Ulrich was laberst du da du
wolltest mich zum Flughafen fahren
ein Fehler sorry
liebe dich
Ulrich von Heesen
rechtet ab mit der sensieg ja der
Fachkräftemangel natürlich auch ein
Problem bei uns also im Witze Business
wie aktuell der Karneval beweist früher
galt ja das wissen Sie über Politiker
macht man keine Witze da lacht man
einfach direkt heute heute nehmen sie
uns selbst das noch weg irgendwer mit
Medien sieht das kritisch
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
juckt mich am Arsch wie war in Köln ist
doch vor dem mit Fastelovend so bequem
oder in Mainz in Münster in Aachen
merken Sie was Bischofssitze die Pfaffen
erlaubten uns hergelaufenen Pöbel vor
der entbehrungsreichen fastenzahlung
also drei Tage alles zu tun was sonst
nur sie dürfen also vor allem hackedicht
Kreuz und quervögeln auch die Fürsten
und Militärs gewährten Meinungsfreiheit
und pardon daran erinnern ja noch die
maßkapellen und Uniformen also künftig
werden ja die Grünen Parteitage so
aussehen grüne kennen Sie ja
jugendkarneval der NATO genau jedenfalls
dieser Volks Karneval ist enorm populär
hessensministerpräsident Boris rein z.B
drängelt auf jedes Jacke Foto wie Kinder
an die Schokolade
Serviervorschlag abbildung ähnlich und
seit das Fernsehen seine Kameras auf die
Bütt richtet sind sie plötzlich alle
wieder da die Obrigkeit drängelt und
Schubs das Volk aus dem Bild in Aachen
waren mehr Politiker im Saal als bei
einer Bundestagssitzung aber Problem ich
bin in der Tat kein sehr lustiger Mensch
meine Tochter meinte mama was hast du
gemacht du willst eine karnevalsrede
halten du bist überhaupt nicht witzig
Kinder und nach dem sagen die Wahrheit
deswegen schickte das Team Politik
erstmal so ein bisschen Fallobst eine
mindere knalltage ins Feuer nur die
Grünen die haben geschmunzelt ein
bisschen
ratlos die waren Lutzerath los
Schrauben weil das lustiger ist
empfindsame Kinder gucken jetzt immer
wieder unterm Bett nach ob da womöglich
die schrille Hexe von der FDP Lauer
einziger echter Lacher des Abends das
Beraterteam von Friedrich Merz nach zwei
kann steiniger flossen Sie unseren Witze
Fritze ein er sei bei Lastwagen und da
gewinnt natürlich bis zum Schluss nicht
lachen aber geschafft kann man danach
gucken ob der da immer noch sitzt guck
mal
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig